so Chuck we with a new tradition we have
in the final segment it's the lightning
round that's what it is and we have a
bell for it you don't have to bail there
it goes okay and I will answer every
question as a sound bite comes right
so we can cram because I take so long oh
and all the other segments try to pack
it as many questions as we have all
right are you ready I am ready set go
for it okay here we go
this is from Lois Moses on Facebook do
dust clouds around stars cause
electrical storms electrical storms in
around the Stars I don't know so here's
what happens the Sun stars the Sun
particularly in this case gives off what
we call a solar wind which are charged
particles and those particles can enter
a dust cloud and ionize the dust cloud
are excited and possibly have it trigger
a phenomenon similar to what we have on
earth like our aurora right so maybe it
maybe there's a rora in nearby dust
clouds two stars I haven't thought it
through but it's certainly possible
there you go got no right this is from
Martha said Becca
Martha what do we know of the star that
exploded to get material to form our
sources you know naive I would love to
name it not oh do you name something
that's dead yes I'm gone and dead that
we can't find anywhere
yes that's Dan gone right just like my
great-grandmother has me oh no I have to
go great great cuz actually knew my
great-grandmother well it's not so five
billion years ago there was a star that
exploded created and Richmond iron
nickel how you know nitrogen oxygen a
lot of the things we find on earth and
in our bodies were forged in a star they
came right before us yes it gave its
life for it for us and that's a good
thing and no sure go ahead and name it
but we have no idea what where the
remains are most of it is just
completely gone well it's all right some
of it in ourselves okay well it died for
us let's call it Jesus
Jesus donkeys and stuff all right here
we go all right let's move on this is
from Sarah Ashley Colding will the Sun
burn out before or after we collide with
them dromeda mmm this is a cool one so
the Sun will burn out there like 5
billion years and look now the collision
with Andromeda is not an overnight thing
we have two huge systems and we'll start
falling towards one another distort that
will happen between 5 and 7 billion
years from now so the death of the Sun
should be our highest priority not the
collision on the drums me down sit back
nicely done
alright um this is from Dennis B via
email hello people might not have known
that we're on a collision course with an
that yeah it's gonna say that's ooh I
forgot to like that's a sensation it
polies you're saying that it's going to
happen oh yeah
but we have other issues before that all
right ok gentlemen it's been a player of
pleasure playing with you that's like
the Titanic all right here we go from
Dennis B via email if the Sun were to
disappear in an instant how quickly will
we land earth know about its gravity Y's
8 minutes and 20 seconds next if the Sun
disappeared we would not know about it
at all we would still orbit we would
still feel as gravity would still feel
as heat and warmth and light for 8
minutes and 20 seconds and all hell
breaks loose what a great movie we fly
off and there's no way you could have
known about it because that information
is moving at the speed of light from the
absence of a Sun to the radius of our
orbit that is fantastic you got it ok
next this is from Kelly Smith by the way
if you can do the math the speed of
light divided into the distance from the
Sun to the earth you're getting minutes
and 20 seconds Emily Harris I can't do
that yes you can you can Kelly Smith
from facebook wants to know Wow
ok I don't know if we could do this in a
sound bite but I'm gonna give it to you
how are you trying stars for them what
is their lifecycle whoo
so a white dwarf star which is they sort
of the first stage of the death of a
star our Sun will become
white dwarf is held that by what's
called electron pressure electrons can't
get it too close to one another they'll
separate right all right it's called
electron pressure electron degeneracy
pressure but you Oh puke a knotwork
overcome that but you can't be an
electron if you come from you can
overcome the electron pressure I
cramming the electrons into the protons
that are in the nucleus that you cram a
negative charge and a positive charge
what do you get
ah beautiful fire yeah you get a
neutrons the the charges cancel and
that's how you make a neutron star
cramming electrons of the blood of a
proton and so then you get a neutron
star far more dense than that that a
white dwarf ever was in fact one cubic
centimeter would wait way as much as
thirty thirty billion elephants you had
via cramming up the buck we got a run
this has been cosmic queries addition of
star talk radio I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
your host thanks Chuck nicely being here